what if we all get together and help
each other and hire a new guy and then
we all kill him but first we take out
like 100 000 life insurance policy i bet
you guys like that idea don't you
i think that's what they're doing to me
i can't prove it but i wanted to see
their faces when i said it i learned
nothing
i don't know what that was carol
carol stills
i would like you
to do me the honor of making me
your husband
oh michael
what are you saying
can we talk about this in private
i didn't hear you
can we talk about this in private
oh you gotta be kidding me
okay
[Music]
the big surprise
is
drumroll
[Music]
the thing that i'm just trying to say to
you jim
and to everyone else in the circle i
guess
is that i miss having fun with you
just you not everyone in circle
okay i am gonna go walk in the water now
yeah
it's a good day
pam
that was amazing
but i am still looking for someone with
a sales background
i feel very blessed
[Music]
ah hey dwight uh
send in the subs
oh
[Laughter]
i have an announcement uh
to make
i
am moving to costa rica
thought about it
for a long time now
and i'm finally gonna do it
so
i'm just gonna hop the fence and jog
home now
what are you doing what are you doing
i'm rejecting your kiss i didn't
guys
we're moving to colorado
all of us yep
wait what
holly has to go back to colorado i'm
going with her i'm leaving
jada what are you doing
oh
so sorry guys i hope my family didn't
disrupt your meeting
daddy are these the people who are
making your manager
maybe sweetheart
single dad challenges
i don't know if he'd be a good manager
but he's a really great dad
okay [ __ ] this was a mistake let's go
hey you phyllis take bob vance vance
refrigeration to be your lawfully wedded
husband
i do ladies and gentlemen may i present
to you for the first time as a couple mr
and mrs bob vance
and do you bob take phyllis to be your
lawfully wedded wife
i love phyllis
you know what else
i think she is gorgeous
i think she is an incredibly
incredibly attractive person
come here come here
come home go come on you don't have to
worry i'm not good i'm not reporting i'm
not worried to hr you know what the only
thing i am worried about
is getting a boner
good work today everybody
times have changed a little luke can i
have that no okay i am going to count
down from five
five four
i'm not kidding
three
two two one
okay
you are going to learn to be more
professional
that's what you're luke to do luke
what the hell was that i had to do that
scroll it all right are we good
you're okay
he's okay
stanley earth is stanley not me yes you
come on stanley put your little game
down and and join the group no
and i want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image
man i want you people to remember for a
long time to come
whenever you come into the office i want
you to think about this
we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
i did it
thank you
thank you thank you see
see that
the obvious symmetry of the face
this is a natural appeal of the
scientific standard of
coinophilia
you